you and Clint Eastwood both got started
around the same time and that you were
both fired from Universal Pictures on
the same day as young guys getting
started out well Clint uh they said you
know you you talk too slow and your your
tooth is chipped and you won't get it
fixed
and uh you're Adam's Apple sticks out I
mean it sticks way out here you know
it's ridiculous it's terrible and they
also told David Jansen that his ears
stuck out too far and I said what's my
problem why are you firing me and they
said you can't act
so we left there and and Clint you know
I've known Clinton forever and Clint
maybe speaks eight nine twelve words a
year you know so we were walking up the
street and I said you know Clint you're
really in trouble and he said why I said
I could learn to act you'll never get
rid of that Adam's apple
it did hold him back yeah poor guy
whatever happened